[Musique]
avec leurs beaux yeux qui christiane
bergevin bonsoir mesdames bonsoir
alors c'est notre collègue romain suez 1
qui est allé écouter bien attentivement
cette cette conférence de françois
legault cette discussion avec le conseil
du patronat du québec qui n'était pas
destinée à être public mais qui a été la
vidéo a été transmise a été diffusée et
donc sur le web
romain publié un texte et un suivi
d'ailleurs ce soir sur les propos de
françois legault sur l'immigration que
je vous rappelle tout de suite je vous
pose des questions ensuite moi mon
obsession c'est d'augmenter salaire
moyen au québec
donc à chaque fois que je rentre un
immigrant qui gagnent moins 50 civils
j'en paye mon problème à chaque fois que
j'entends un immigrant qui gagnent plus
que cinquante six mille j'améliore ma
situation
alors christiane d'abord votre réaction
c'était sûrement pas la meilleure
situation est le meilleur moment du
premier du québec
évidemment qu'on a besoin des
travailleurs qualifiés des travailleurs
bien payés au juste dans le monde de la
technologie mais dans des métiers
traditionnels on trouve plus de plombier
on trouve plus d'électriciens de soudeur
alors il ya un besoin de travailleurs
qualifiés au salaire mais de la même
façon on a besoin des travailleurs dans
le milieu des services de santé dans les
loisirs dans les services de garde
donc on a besoin de balancer les choses
une société bien balancé c'est une
société qui investit dans la formation
qui forment ce travail est clair en fait
si on regarde le milieu agricole ce sont
des travailleurs saisonniers étrangers
qui font qu'ils soutiennent ce secteur
là de façon importante dans le contexte
les gens n'ont pas installé de cinquante
six mille dollars et pourtant ils sont
essentiels au fonctionnement du québec
donc tout tous les métiers tous les
ouvriers tous les emplois de base
devrait être valorisée dans le contexte
on a besoin de tout le monde
on manque de travailleurs de main
d'oeuvre dans tous les domaines dans
tous les secteurs
lui ce qu'il dit c'est que je suis prêt
à intervenir en faveur des employeurs
qui ont besoin de combler des postes à
56 1000 $ et plus
par la voix de l'immigration notamment
pour les autres je ne peux pas rien
faire est-ce que c'est cohérent avec une
approche vous l'a augmentée salaire
moyen christiane mais l'écouté on a vu
cette semaine l'annoncé du fédéral qui
va privilégier le statut permanent pour
90 mille personnes 50 mille travailleurs
a permis temporaire de quarante mille
étudiants internationaux qui ont gradué
ainsi il ya bien des façons d'amener de
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée et oui
d'amener des travailleurs à haut niveau
ça fait augmenter le travailleur moyen
mais si on investit en formation sont
investis en technologie si nos
entreprises sont plus compétitives ils
vont engager des travailleurs
d'elle-même à plus hauts salaires donc
on va atteindre le même niveau
est ce que c est ce que c'est un facteur
d'appauvrissement la vision que le
premier ministre a de l'immigration ou
d'enrichissement parce que quand il dit
en botte 56100 empire mon problème donc
ça vient appauvrir le québec et à
couvrir le salaire moyen comment comment
on peut voir les migrations avec avec
ses lunettes là par le prisme du salaire
moyen clair mais en fait c'est de le
considérer seulement sous le en termes
d'unités de travail en termes
économiques
alors que l'arrivée d'immigrants qui
vont avoir peut-être installé en moins
grand mais dont les enfants pourront
accéder à des études et peut-être avoir
un meilleur salaire justement c'est
aussi une partie de la solution
dans notre société il ya 20 30 40 ans on
les oppose et les enfants qui auraient
pu être de la main d'oeuvre actuellement
dans le contexte on va avoir besoin des
immigrants et de toutes les catégories
d'immigrants et de tous les travaux war
et si tu mets des flots de toute façon
on en aurait besoin même si ce ne sont
pas des miracles que les emplois ce sont
des emplois qui sont disponibles pour
lesquelles on a besoin d'eux mais donne
donc est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
dire au patron de mieux payer leurs
employés christiane ben je crois qu'il
faut dire au patron d'investir en
technologie d'investir en formation ces
poteaux d'accueillir des gens bien les
pays faut les intégrer faut les former
et les meilleurs pays le canada c est au
12e rang sur 16 au niveau des pays qui
manque d'innovation avec je crois que si
on amène des conditions gagnantes
les employés des entreprises vont
prospérer les employés vont être mieux
payé c'est tout simple ouais québec veut
augmenter la part de l'immigration
économique
c'est ce qu'a dit aussi le premier
ministre qui a des annonces qui doit se
faire
prochainement est ce que c'est la chose
à faire à court terme est clair en fait
à court terme faut avoir un équilibre
s'est pas seulement il d'immigration
économique c'est aussi les milieux dits
c'est aussi la cohésion dans les milieux
de vie c'est comment on accueille ces
gens là comment on les retient comme on
les intègre à notre société
alors c'est un ensemble et c'est pas
ceux de considérer les immigrants
seulement en termes économiques c'est
une erreur pour toute notre société de
façon trop utilitaire dans un sens dans
le discours en tout cas il se fait est
ce qu'on doit pas dire aussi que est-ce
que c'est l'immigration totale qui
devrait pas augmenter au canada au
québec qu'on accueille quarante mille
migrants à peu près alors même si on
accroît les migrations économiques sur
40000 c'est un petit nom son regard de
l'ontario il ya triplé thériault attire
3 fois plus d'immigrants que le québec
alors donc alors qu'ils ont deux fois
notre taille et au canada l'immigration
a augmenté de 35% lors si le chiffre
total augmente va l'immigration
économique va augmenter de la même façon
mais avec la proche du premier ministre
ce qu'il nous dit aujourd'hui parce que
je regardais le tableau des postes
vacants
la grande majorité des postes vacants à
combler offrent des salaires moyens de
14 15 20 21 $ 22 dollars on est loin du
28 dollars qui nous amène aux cinquante
six mille dollars pour un poste à temps
plein et pourtant on absolument besoin
de ces emplois là on absolument besoin
ils sont à la base ce organe qui occuper
les emplois dans les cfc dès qu'ils
occupent les emplois de l'agriculture
qui occupent les emplois de base qui
génère c'est le soutien de base de notre
société se sont pas des gens qui gagnent
cinquante six mille dollars par année
on a besoin de valoriser tous ses
employés il ya des grosses négociations
difficiles dans le secteur public
monsieur legault est sorti en fin de
semaine pour en parler
certains ont fait remarquer que c'est
pas tout le monde qui gagne au moins 56
mis dans la fonction publique en santé
en éducation
questionne est ce que québec doit donner
l'exemple dans le fond si on veut
montée du salaire je me semblerait que
ce serait la première mesure allait
planter ce serait logique
oui ce qui est beau sexy ce qui est bon
pour minou est bon pour pitou
ceci induit au secteur privé d'avoir des
bons salaires le secteur public va
offrir les mêmes d'ailleurs la
difficulté de recrutement dans ce
secteur est un symptôme clients du site
que les salaires ne sont pas compétitifs
je suis vous alliez ajouté oui je
l'ajouté que si on regarde ailleurs si
on regarde du côté de l'allemagne pays
extrêmement productif productivité
meilleure qu'ici il prévoit 3 millions
une pénurie de trois millions d'emplois
d'ici 2030 et ces emplois là il est il y
mentionne dans le secteur de la santé
dans le secteur de l'ingénierie au
secteur des métiers de base
et je me dis pas si au pays comme
l'allemagne fait un effort tout azimut
dans toutes les catégories
pourquoi nous ici on fera un effort
seulement dans les cinquante six mille
en montant ouais alors on va s'arrêter
ici un dernier mot de votre part claire
vous signé la préface du livre de louis
robert pour le bien de la terre louise
robert qui fait la manchette depuis
quelques jours et à la suite donc de la
dénonciation de louis robert de ministre
de l'agriculture monsieur la montagne a
reconnu en fin de semaine qu'on utilise
trop de pesticides au québec et il
souhaite qu'il y ait plus d'ambiguïté
entre le conseil d'une part et la vente
en dd des produits vous signez donc
cette préface est ce que vous croyez le
ministre la montagne quand elle jure
qu'il met toutes ses actions en place
pour changer ce que dénonce louis robert
je connais monsieur la montagne c'est un
homme de bonne volonté et je vais je
pense que oui il le croit
fondamentalement en ce qu'il dit par
contre quand on veut changer des choses
il le présentait le plan agriculture
durable en octobre dernier quand on veut
changer des choses il faut porter le
message haut et fort le porter et être
associé à des personnes qui vont le
porter avec nous et dans le contexte
c'est la même équipe de dirigeants au
ministère de l'agriculture actuellement
qui étaient partie prenante de la
problématique
alors est ce que ce sont les bonnes
personnes pour faire des changements moi
je pense que monsieur lâm
tant il doit être très bien accompagné %
les changements qu'il veut il a la
volonté pour le faire c'est un homme de
bonne volonté alors je pense qu'il doit
être accompagnée porter un message ou
efforts par mille que les faire ok
message lancé claire merci christiane
merci beaucoup fait pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit